ce déplacement aujourd'hui à beyrouth
avec vous et à vos côtés après avoir vu
entendu et écouté aujourd'hui les
regards et les voix de nos de nos frères
libanais en ce jour d'après le 4 août
2020 vous dire combien je ressens une
une infinie tristesse une profonde
solidarité et partage la scène colère
que nous avons vu s'exprimer aujourd'hui
l'objet de ce déplacement nous avons
effectué ce jour était d'abord et avant
tout celui de d'un soutien au peuple
libanais un liban libre fier et
souverain
et dire que dans ces moments là il n'y a
qu'une évidence être présent et et dès
que nous avons fait dès les premières
heures et je vais y revenir et c'est ce
pour quoi nous devions être là
aujourd'hui
cette solidarité cette fraternité c'est
celle de tout le peuple français à
l'endroit du peuple libanais nous vous
accompagnerons sur ce chemin aujourd'hui
demain nous serons là et la france ne
lâchera jamais le liban elle
n'abandonnera jamais les libanaises et
les libanais jamais
nos destins sont noués indéfectiblement
par les liens du temps de l'esprit de
l'âme de la culture des rêves et en ce
jour de deuil à beyrouth mille fois
morte
mille fois revécu la france entière dit
aujourd'hui qu'elle est à ses côtés et
que lorsque le liban est frappée au
coeur comme il l'est aujourd'hui c'est
aussi le coeur de la france qui ait
frappé et je veux adresser ici toutes
mes condoléances aux familles qui ont
été touchés il ya une cinquantaine de
françaises et de français qui ont été
touchées au moins il est trop tôt pour
donner des chiffres les précisions
il y a des milliers dizaines de milliers
de libanais et de libanais qui ont été
touchés qui ont des victimes dans leurs
familles des disparus des blessés je
veux leur adresser à toutes et tous la
solidarité de la france et mes
condoléances l'urgence c'est d'abord et
avant tout le led
face à l'urgence absolue tous les moyens
de la france sont d'ores et déjà entrés
en action
trois avions deux avions militaires et
un avion grâce au soutien du groupe
cma-cgm et je l'en remercie ont pu
arriver dès hier après-midi avec à leur
bord un détachement de la sécurité
civile des personnes à l'urgentiste qui
ont été ainsi acheminé un poste
sanitaire mobile permettant la prise en
charge de 500 blessés toutes ces
personnes sont à pied d'oeuvre
nous les avons vu ce matin sur le site
du port et au delà je veux vous dire que
les soutiens affluent de la part de la
population française qui se mobilisent
dans son ensemble des collectivités
territoriales beaucoup de villes
départements de région se sont aussi
mobilisés et un élan fraternel est là et
tout les binationaux comme la communauté
sont pleinement mobilisés pour aider à
cette aide
dans quelques heures un nouveau avions
ravitailleurs mrtt atterrira sur le sol
libanais avec des équipes de soutien de
secours des enquêteurs pour aider à
avancer
justement dans les investigations les
recherches recherche à la fois de corps
et investigations pour tirer au clair
cette enquête et j'y reviendrai jeudi
prochain le bepc le tonnerre arrivera au
liban en effet ce porte-hélicoptères
amphibie partira de france pour
retrouver le liban et y apporter des
médicaments
des équipes d'urgence des soignants des
capacités aussi de soins pour répondre à
l'urgence des blessés cette solidarité
nous allons la poursuivre afin d'aider
toutes celles et ceux qui sur le terrain
agissent comme nous l'avons vu ce matin
au port comme dans les différents
quartiers
c'est un besoin de soignants de
médicaments de nourriture de matériaux
aussi pour reconstruire le plus
rapidement possible les habitations des
300000 au moins libanaise et libanais
qui aujourd'hui n'ont plus de toit ou de
maison en état et là aussi nous sommes
pleinement mobilisés je veux remercier
les entreprises françaises qui ont déjà
fait savoir qu'elles étaient prêtes à
offrir qui du blé qui des verts de
construction remercié celles qui ont
d'ores et déjà dit qu'elle aiderait à
acheminer cette mobilisation va se
poursuivre et nous allons organiser nous
serons là dans la durée aux côtés de
toutes celles et ceux qui sauvent aide
guérissent reconstruise la france sera
aussi là pour organiser l'aide
internationale aux côtés de l'union
européenne des nations unies avec le
soutien de la banque mondiale dans les
tout prochains jours nous organiserons
et le ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères a commencé à prendre
les premiers contacts et a mobilisé ses
équipes
nous organiserons une conférence
internationale de soutien et d'appui à
beyrouth et la population libanaise avec
pour objectif de mobiliser les
financements internationaux des
européens les américains 2
tous les pays de la région et au delà
afin de fournir des médicaments et des
soins la nourriture le nécessaire pour
les logements
nous mettrons aussi en place une
gouvernance claire et transparente pour
que l'ensemble de cette aide
qu'il s'agisse de l'aide française comme
de l'aide internationale soit
directement acheminés aux populations
aux organisations non gouvernementales
aux équipes sur le terrain qui en ont
besoin sans qu' aucune opacité aucun
détournement ne soit possible
les nations unies la banque mondiale
joueront un rôle essentiel en la matière
pour définir clairement les besoins et
permettre à la communauté internationale
comme au peuple libanais d'avoir la
pleine transparence sur les cheminements
de l'ensemble de cette aide il y aura un
avant et un après 4 août 2020 parce que
cette effroyable détonation a sonné
comme un coup de tonnerre sur la pente
du désespoir
et si le liban se réveille aujourd'hui
meurtrie et épuisé je sais qu'il se
relèvera avec tout ce qui fait sa force
et a fait sa force dans son histoire et
qu'il a les capacités d'un rebond il y a
dans la détonation du 4 août quelque
chose comme la métaphore de la crise
contemporaine du liban comme le résultat
de ce à quoi peut conduire quelque chose
dont on ne s'occupe pas un endroit dont
on ne s'occupe plus et il y avait ce
matin dans la colère de la jeunesse et
de la rue pour moi aussi les ingrédients
d'un formidable espoir
je veux ici dira
toutes les libanaises et tous les
libanais en particulier aux plus jeunes
que nous serons à leurs côtés au delà de
cette aide d'urgence que je viens
d'évoquer de ce soutien nous serons à
leurs côtés d'abord pour éduquer le
ministre était là il ya quelques
semaines a évoqué d'abord les 15
millions d'euros mobilisés pour les
écoles francophones et la mise en place
de ce fonds pour les écoles d'orient
fonds de 2 millions qui permettra
d'aller plus loin grâce aux
collectivités territoriales et aux
partenaires privés d'ici au 1er
septembre nous irons plus loin pour
soutenir les écoles ici les universités
et permettre d'apporter la réponse
financière pour la jeunesse libanaise je
souhaite aussi qu'on puisse en
partenariat avec l'ensemble des
donateurs privés aider les jeunes qui
ont besoin d'aller faire leurs études à
l'étranger à pouvoir les faire par des
systèmes de bourses
certaines existent déjà nous devons
aller beaucoup plus loin
on ne doit pas dans cette période oublié
et en rien les la force de l'éducation
du savoir et donc nous serons aux côtés
des écoles des universités et de la
jeunesse pour qu'elle puisse continuer à
apprendre à apprendre pour aimer la
liberté et l'exigence de la liberté qui
va avec
ensuite c'est la culture et la liberté
d'expression quand le monde s'assombrit
la tentation est grande
d'oublier ce pourquoi on mène tous les
combats
savoir qu'il ya autre chose de possible
savoir qu'il ya quelque chose de plus
grand que le quotidien est un absolu le
savoir la vérité
l'expression de chacun il est important
dans cette période que la liberté
d'expression la liberté du journalisme
la capacité à créer se poursuivre au
liban il ya aussi la réponse économique
nous avons il ya plus de deux ans
conduit les conférences à paris pour que
la réponse économique soit apportée les
réformes d'un côté dans le secteur de
l'énergie de l'électricité de la
commande publique des douanes de la
lutte contre la corruption
les financements de l'autre nous nous
sommes mobilisés les financements sont
là ils attendent les réformes
l'agenda de paris les conférences cèdre
les réformes économiques et le soutien
de la communauté internationale
n'attendent que ce sursaut aussi face à
la colère et la défiance l'espoir que je
nourris et l'appel que j'ai pu faire ce
matin au président aoun aussi au
président du parlement nabih berri au
premier ministre hassan diab est l
ensemble des représentants des forces
politiques
c'est le temps des responsabilités pour
le liban aujourd'hui et ses dirigeants
il faut rebâtir la confiance et l'espoir
elle ne se décrète pas elle ne se
reconquérir pas du jour au lendemain
mais elle suppose une refondation d'un
ordre politique nouveau où chacun au
delà des divisions dans lesquelles il
s'est réfugié dans un confessionnalisme
qui a été parfois capturer d'un système
qui a été lui aussi
capturé par une corruption organisée
d'avoir la force de rebâtir une union
nationale pour mener les réformes
indispensables dans les libanaises des
libanais ont besoin de procéder aux
opérations de transparence indispensable
sur le système bancaire la banque
centrale de le faire dans un cadre
international de coopérer avec le fonds
monétaire international
je me battrai pour que la solidarité
internationale soit là celle du fmi de
tous les grands pays
mais je ne peux me substituer aux
responsabilités d'un gouvernement
souverainement élus d'un président
souverainement élus leur responsabilité
est immense c'est celle d'une
refondation d'un nouveau pacte avec le
peuple libanais dans les prochaines
semaines ce changement profond c'est
celui qui est attendu les dirigeants les
forces politiques libanaises ont
aujourd'hui une démonstration affaire
celle de leur capacité à y répondre
je le dis avec à la fois beaucoup
d'humilité et beaucoup d'exigences
l'humilité d'un président français qui
n'a pas à dicter à des dirigeants
libanais ce qu'ils doivent faire
l'exigence d'un ami qui se précipitent
quand les temps sont durs mais pas pour
donner des chèques en blanc à des
systèmes qui n'ont plus la confiance de
leurs peuples
et donc cette humilité cette exigence
c'est celle que je veux pour nous tous
dans les prochaines semaines je serai là
en soutien avec l'ensemble des
dirigeants
j'ai été franc direct sincère
aujourd'hui avec chacun d'entre eux et
j'attends des autorités libanaises des
réponses claires sur leur engagement
l'état de droit la transparence la
liberté la démocratie les réformes
indispensables
je les crois capables
je reviendrai le 1er septembre prochain
je reviendrai pour pas simplement
consacré l'histoire et le fait que ici
même dans cet endroit dans cette
résidence des pins il ya cent ans jour
pour jour alors le 1er septembre le
grand liban mais c'est non je reviendrai
pour faire un point d'étape ensemble de
cette indispensable sursaut parce que je
pense qu'il n'y a pas d'autre voie pour
le liban contemporain la france c'est le
poids de cette amitié elle en a parfois
payé le prix du sang dans quelques
instants je célébrerai la mémoire des 58
militaires français tués lors des
attentats devra car nous savons le prix
le prix du sang du terrorisme la morsure
mais nous savons aussi que nous pouvons
relever tous les défis ensemble et je
sais que le peuple libanais est capable
de relever ce défi voilà ce que j'étais
venu aujourd'hui vous dire vous dire que
n'oubliez jamais quelles que soient les
difficultés du quotidien qu'il y à un
peuple d'europe le peuple français dont
le coeur bat toujours un peu à la
pulsation de beyrouth
parce qu'il sait qu'ici il ya un peuple
qui aime la liberté
l'unité et le respect de l'autre
il y à un peuple qui dans une région où
le pire et parfois devenus ou tout à
céder au terrorisme à l'obscurantisme
nous savons qu'il ya un peuple qui aime
la liberté la culture la civilisation le
respect de l'autre
[Applaudissements]
alors à chaque fois que vous douterez
dites vous que nous serons là à chaque
fois que je voudrais mener le combat
nous le mènerons à vos côtés et quand
vous vous demanderez ce qu'on pense à
paris
retenez juste ces mots les bacs et à
lausanne
[Applaudissements]
je vais répondre à vos questions
on va commencer s'il vous plaît il ya un
ordre pour les questions je proposais
harris question alors regardez on va
vous donner la parole je crois juste
après ils pensent ils vont essayer de
faire un ordre
je vous promets que vous poserez votre
question d'accord bonsoir monsieur le
président merci d'être venus jusqu'à
beyrouth
vous avez parlé d'un besoin de
refondation d'un ordre politique au
liban les libanais entendent un
changement de constitution
est-ce que vous pouvez être un peu plus
explicite qu'est ce que vous avez
demandé à ses dirigeants politiques que
vous avez réuni autour de cette table
ronde
et vous dites que vous allez revenir le
1er septembre
est ce que vous voulez que cette
fondation souhaite entamer d'ici le 1er
septembre et comment est ce que vous
allez y arriver puisque ça fait plus
d'un an que les libanais demande cette
refondation mais n'y arrive pas d'abord
l'histoire nous a montré qu' il ne faut
jamais désespérer avec le temps et que
lorsque le pire et là on est au bord du
gouffre il ya ici une force d'âme pour
saisir le kairos et je crois que c'est
maintenant
ensuite il ne m'appartient pas moi de
dire il faut changer la constitution
il faut mener une transition ou autre je
suis président de la république
française ce que je sais c'est que nous
avons un dialogue depuis des mois des
années pour dire ce qu'il faut faire ce
que je sais c'est qu'aujourd'hui des
libanaises et libanais ont des dizaines
de coupures de courant chaque jour que
de plus en plus ne mangent pas à leur
faim que des ruptures
d'approvisionnement sont à prévoir que
tout un pays qui tenait sur un système
financier basé sur l'import export est
en train de s'effondrer par la défiance
à l'égard dû système bancaire et de la
banque centrale
et donc il ya des réponses de court
terme amener que l'on connaît
lutter contre la corruption réformer le
système de l'énergie et de l'électricité
le système des douanes
permettent la transparence des
approvisionnements permettre derrière et
exiger les réformes sur l'ensemble de
ces secteurs et les commencer vite
ensuite il ya la nécessité de mener un
audit sur le système bancaire et la
banque centrale si on veut recapitaliser
hre mobiliser de l'argent international
du fmi et d'autres pays
personne ne le fera pas tant qu'on ne
sait pas combien manque beaucoup pas été
détournés à coup sûr beaucoup pour
toucher de l'argent c'est certain est-ce
que ça doit justifier une forme de loi
du silence qui est en même temps celle
de l'impuissance
non parce qu'il n'ya qu'un martyr de
tout cela le peuple libanais un seul
martyr il ya toujours des arrangements
qui sont trouvés on le sait très bien et
donc j'espère qu'avec le temps le peuple
libanais trouvera la capacité de faire
émerger une offre politique qui
correspond à ses aspirations
les réformes qui vont avec ce n'est pas
à moi de les prescrire mais ce dont je
viens de vous parler ce sont des
réformes vitales de court terme
s'il n'y a pas cet audit qui est fait
sur la banque centrale et le lancement
véritablement avec le fonds mondial
international de ce travail dans
quelques mois il n'y aura plus
d'importation dans quelques mois sans
doute le fuel manquera pour éclairer la
nourriture manquera et ça ce sera la
responsabilité de ceux qui ont refusé
aujourd'hui de faire ce travail il peut
encore être fait maintenant et donc je
les ai engagé à faire et je le dis avec
encore une fois exigences et humilité et
respect et donc voilà de manière très
concrète c'est ça ce que j'ai ce à quoi
j'ai appelé de mes voeux la france aide
elle est là elle continuera d'aider nous
avons organisé des conférences
internationales on a levé de l'argent on
continuera de le faire mais on ne peut
le faire que si les dirigeants libanais
prendre leurs responsabilités pour nous
permettre de les aider pleinement et
d'aider pleinement les libanaises et
libanais bonsoir monsieur le président
permettez moi au début de vous le mais
c'est infiniment tous vos paroles
touchantes envers les libanais envers le
peuple libanais merci beaucoup monsieur
le président
est ce que la france est prête à
participer ou à coop art va trôner avec
le liban une commission ad-hoc d'
enquête et sous quelles conditions
surtout qu'il y a des français entre
blessés est mort il est ma deuxième
question s'il vous plaît comment la
france va t-elle coordonnées pour un
fonds de reconstruction avec quels
partis internationale spécialement merci
j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger avec le
président comme le premier ministre sur
ce sujet des premières coopérations
techniques ont été demandés et je crois
qu'en effet l' enquête internationale
est une question de confiance
toute la lumière vous l'avez dit doit
être fait c'est pourquoi j'ai demandé
aux autorités libanaises de répondre à
cette demande forte et légitime de
prendre en compte pour cela des experts
français disponible immédiatement
nous en avons fait l'offre mais aussi
des experts internationaux chacun dans
leurs compétences
je crois que c'est une question de
clarté et de crédibilité donc oui j'y
suis favorable
il nous apporterons toutes les
contributions qui nous seront demandées
sur l'aide et le soutien de court terme
et d'urgence ont souhaité que cela soit
supervisée par les nations unies qui
sont présentes ici dont nous avons vu ce
matin au port l'une des représentants la
france sera à vos côtés nous apporterons
là aussi tout notre soutien technique et
notre expertise sur ce point mais je
pense que les nations unies sont toutes
désignées pour coordonner l'aide à la
fois l'expression des besoins avec
l'ensemble des acteurs acteurs publics
services d'urgence mais aussi ong
associations et pour organiser l'aide
sur le terrain
le quatre sans doute en aussi en lien
avec la banque mondiale qui a des
capacités un savoir faire sur ce point
et donc je pense que c'est aux
organisations internationales de le
faire et c'est ainsi que nous allons
structurer les choses
la france apporte la force la france
pardon apportera son soutien mais je
pense que c'est les nations unies la
banque mondiale qui doivent permettre de
coordonner cela en lien avec les acteurs
de terrain je le président mon avis il
ya d'autres questions venez à la suite
là pour que ce soit organisé en journée
une très courte donc mais votre réponse
en revanche peut être longue
est-ce que jusqu où la france est prête
à aller pour encourager les dirigeants
libanais à réformer est-ce que vous
excluez l'imposition de sanctions contre
ceux qui empêchent de réformer sanctions
individuelles à définir je n'exclus rien
mais je pense qu'il faut faire les
choses en bon ordre
nous avons mené des conférences force
est de constater que les réformes
auxquelles s'était engagée le liban
n'ont pas été tenues aujourd'hui ça a
été un échange de vérité fort direct
sincère les prochaines semaines
devraient être consacrés au travail et
je pense que c'est par une pression un
travail conjoint qu'il faut plutôt faire
avancer les choses mais je n'exclus rien
pascal héry des sanctions je n'exclus
rien simplement
l'expérience récente nous a montré que
dans certains contextes et les sanctions
ne sont pas forcément ce qu'il y ait
plus efficace je pense ensuite qu' il
est plus efficace d'essayer de réengager
tout le monde dans un processus mais à
ce stade où nous en sommes je n'exclus
rien est-ce que je pense que c'est la
priorité en termes d'actions non mais je
ne l'exclus pas pour la suite je vous le
confirme et bien on samso le président
série de la nbc tv est aussi deux
quotidiens en allait de l'orient le jour
au nom de mes collègues j'ai deux
questions en une également
pourquoi vous avez parlé le matin d'un
changement de système
devant le peuple et l'après midi on a vu
que vous avez réuni tous les
représentants des partis politiques pour
proposer une formation d'un cabinet
d'union nationale pour affronter la
crise politique économique et financière
de quels changements s'agit-il ici est
la deuxième question à propos de
l'investigation internationale sur
l'explosion du port on a commencé à
entendre des facs et les clame cette
demande est ce que vous vous appuyer
cette demande
alors je veux bien prendre plus de
questions qu'il n'était prévu à la
condition que vous écoutiez les réponses
que je suis aux autres questions
oui donc dans votre deuxième question je
viens d'y répondre
donc je ne vais pas y répondre à nouveau
j'ai déjà répondu sur l' enquête
internationale sur le première question
encore une fois c'est pas à moi de
désigner qui est légitime qui ne l'est
pas je trouve que mon rôle c'est d'avoir
ce même dialogue
j'ai tenu le même discours au peuple
libanais dans la rue à votre président
de la république à votre premier
ministre votre président de l'assemblée
nationale et à toutes les forces
politiques
j'ai ensuite vu aussi d'autres partis
politiques et la société civile qui ne
sont pas dans votre représentation
nationale parce que ils n'ont
aujourd'hui pas passer des élections
c'est pas à moi de dire de recomposer la
vie politique libanaise c'est à moi de
dire il faut aujourd'hui avoir l'énergie
d'apporter les réponses concrètes pour
relever ces défis
c'est à vous décrire votre histoire
mais le rôle de la france c'est d'être
en amitié à vos côtés d'avoir cette
exigence à l'égard des dirigeants de la
classe politique qui est en place
d'avoir aussi cet espoir l'égard de la
société civile de toutes celles et ceux
qui portent d'autres projets et de les
aider et de vous aider à écrire votre
histoire
mais ça n'est pas un président français
de l'écrire à votre
merci monsieur le président j'ai deux
questions si vous permettez
la première vous avez réuni les
dirigeants les représentants des partis
politiques du liban et concluait ce
bolaris conclut le hezbollah à votre
table de dialogue vous allez vous avez
voulu faire lancer un message qui dit
faire aux états unis que le hezbollah
est imparti fondamental dans la société
libanaise et un parti dont le du
gouvernement libanais c'est la première
question est la seconde question à
propos de la déclaration du premier
ministre assez un diable qui avait
déclaré il y avait quelques quelques
jours que le ministre des affaires
étrangères jean yves le drian manquer
d'informations à propos des réformes
demandées
que dites vous alors sur la première
question je n'en vois le message à
personne à l'extérieur je pense que le
problème du liban est d'avoir trop de
monde autour
je suis un grand partisan de la
politique de désastre ciation je suis
pour que au liban on s'occupe des
libanaises et des libanais est donc
aujourd'hui il ya des partis politiques
ce n'est pas moi qui les ai choisi ce
n'est pas moi qui ai mis autour de la
table de force politique ni à votre
parlement ce sont vos choix
je veux simplement dire je peux pas
détourner le visage pour dire je vais
travailler qu'avec une partie des autres
jeux je ne partage pas leurs idées mais
je ne suis pas libanais je dis
simplement on doit travailler avec eux
et donc il faut simplement les mettre
autour de la table parce qu'il faut la
même exigence à leur endroit
s'ils sont libanais si vous défendre
l'intérêt du liban qu'ils aident à
réparer les coupures d'électricité à
nourrir le peuple à éduquer et qu'il ne
fasse pas l'intérêt d'une puissance
extérieure contre les libanaises et les
libanais c'est en étant en phase ii
qu'on peut leur dire c'est ce que j'ai
fait tout à l'heure sur la deuxième
question je dirais je n'ai pas entendu
ces phrases j'aime pas trop faire de
commentaires de presse à presse j'ai eu
le sentiment ce matin que les libanaises
et les libanais n'étaient pas totalement
informés des réformes fait non plus
[Applaudissements]
si président vous avez parlé maintenant
du hezbollah moi je vais un peu plus
loin c'est un parti hégémonique et c'est
un parti qui domine la classe politique
libanaise actuellement je voudrais
savoir votre idée sur le pacte que ces
responsables doivent faire comment
peut-on faire un pacte avec un parti qui
a une arme et illégitime
en face d'une armée légitime et qui
exécute les politiques des iraniens des
syriens et la distanciation dont vous
parlez n'existe pas donc quelques est ce
que est ce que vous vous allez parler
aux iraniens vous allez faire une
médiation
comment voit comment on va résoudre ce
problème car c'est le problème du liban
alors en matière de médiation iranienne
j'ai vraiment souvent essayé avec des
fortunes diverses
comme vous le savez donc je n'ai aucune
naïveté je partage tout ce que vous
venez de dire de la réalité de la
situation mais je regarde aussi les
forces politiques tels que le son sont
organisés et defacto comment votre
système politique s'est organisée et je
ne peux pas faire comme si cela n'était
pas ils sont là mais derrière eux il ya
des libanaises et des libanais aussi la
question c'est comment on rebâtit une
unité comment on sort d'une
privatisation des intérêts ou d'une
soumission à des puissances extérieures
pour retrouver une vraie souveraineté
libanaise qui passe par une armée
libanaise souveraine qui ne dépend pas
d'intérêts extérieurs
ça fait partie de cette refondation mais
ce pacte entendons nous bien
c'est un pacte des formations politiques
existantes nouvelle est à venir avec le
peuple libanais je pense que notre rôle
c'est d'essayer d'aider à cette
émergence par l'aide par l'exigence
politique par la franchise que j'ai ce
soir avec vous mais ça ne se fera pas
d'un coup de baguette magique
ce n'est pas moi qui depuis maintenant
quinze ans les ennemis au gouvernement
les effets rentrer dans le système ce
n'est pas moi mais je serai lâche ou
hypocrite de vous dire ils ne sont pas
là et donc il faut re rendre le peuple
plus fort et ses instruments de
souveraineté pour que toutes les
sensibilités soient prises en compte
sans que ce soit fait aux dépens des
intérêts du peuple et de sa souveraineté
j'ai pas la réponse si quelqu'un avait
la solution ce qui vous prêt qui
prétendent avoir une solution ce sont
ceux qui veulent les remplacer pour une
même hégémonie en vous disant c'est moi
qui vais les remplacer je vais vous
protéger
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
c'est ce qui fait qu'elle est si trouble
si complexe si hésitante c'est que ces
cas la caractéristique d'une crise le
neuf est en train d'émerger et l'ancien
tarder à disparaître et il faut que tout
ça se fasse de la manière la meilleure
possible pour le peuple donc je n'ai pas
de naïveté mais j'ai cette exigence
monsieur le président lyndon chubbuck
mba thiviers deux petites questions
la première on va faire une rallonge et
que j'aie jamais au delà des horaires je
prendrai une question rapide par période
et se sont changés système c'est à dire
vous avez une ligne la france a une
initiative pour la solution politique du
liban
c'est à dire changer régime tas et sous
le patronage de la france
deuxième question croyance en une seule
explosion si non vous n'êtes pas correct
avec vos collègues parce qu'après je
dois filer sur la première question sur
la première question j ai déjà répondu
y'a pas une solution française il ya il
peut y avoir une méthode que nous
accompagnons l'exigence des réformes de
court terme pour les pour le peuple
libanais et les conditions pour
l'émergence d'une offre politique et des
réformes indispensables dans le champ
politique ggg après très longuement
répondu d'ores et déjà parce que vous
nous demandez et donc il faut à la fois
l'énergie du peuple l'esprit de
responsabilité des dirigeants et la
pression que nous allons exercer mais
vous ne pouvez pas me demander de me
substituer à vos dirigeants
c'est pas possible
en tout cas ce serait pas une solution
je ne vous rendrait pas service à faire
ça monsieur le président c'est joe stack
l'égide de la mtv
les responsables libanais ont tué le
peuple le 4 août et ils sont tous
corrompus
vous avez visité le port à votre avis
est-ce que à côté de l'ammonium il y
avait un dépôt de feux d'artifice où il
y avait un dépôt de ministres minutieux
illégal
je sais pas le dire la conte la
confiance elle ne se bâtit que sur la
vérité les faits la dialectique qui va
avec
je n'ai aucune information en ma
possession au delà des informations
publiques qui sont les vôtres
c'est pourquoi il faut une enquête
internationale ouverte transparente pour
éviter que d'abord des choses soient
cachés mais aussi que le doute ne
s'installe donc je n'ai je ne peux pas
répondre à votre question parce que je
n'ai aucune information
au delà de ce que vous savez mais j'ai
vu avec beaucoup d'émotion le le drame
qui s'est noué la violence de cette
explosion
les corps ensevelis et je l'espère
encore quelques quelques vies qu'on
pourra sauver dans les prochaines heures
et ce sont les responsables libanais qui
ont titillé le peuple à votre avis je je
vais pas moi je vais pas moi donner des
accusations alors que je défend le
principe d'une enquête indépendante et
transparente
merci monsieur le président s'il vous
plaît ces dix là ramadan tabala de télé
liban s'il vous plaît vous avez ressenti
un attachement fort de la part du
gouvernement libanais pour les réformes
de s'être je suis pas là pour qualifier
ce que je ressens je suis là pour voir
ce qui existe et donc j'attends de voir
j'attends de voir ces avril avril 2018
ce monsieur le ministre un avril 2018
elles n'ont pas été faites
ça n'est pas vrai et donc quelle a été
votre message monsieur le président paul
inconvénients libanais
ça l'exigence oui celui que je viens de
donner merci m
de la même manière c'est le président le
patriarche maronite allez j'en prends
deux derniers parce que là vraiment je
suis au delà des mes vous rencontrer les
présidents anciens et corrompus au liban
qui ont tué le peuple libanais et qui
ont tué des français de même donc
comment mais qu'il fallait il que je
rencontre mais je les ai rencontrés ce
matin le peuple mérite la difficulté je
vais répondre à votre question qui m'a
déjà été posée à laquelle j'ai déjà
répondu
le paradoxe dans lequel vous êtes c'est
que depuis octobre dernier
vous avez en effet un mouvement dans
lequel j'ai un infini respect qui s'est
soulevée mais il n'a pas trouvé
aujourd'hui sa traduction politique en
tant que président de la république
française je n'ai pas à dire les
responsables politiques qui ont été dans
un système que vous contestez
légitimement élu et qui vous représente
n'existe plus je ne venais pas non plus
- sans preuve à dire ils ont telle ou
telle responsabilité
quelle est ma - ma responsabilité aider
le peuple ce que je fais en venant avoir
un discours de vérité d'exigence avec
eux je les ai eus je peux vous le dire
attendre que dans des échéances précises
des mouvements pousser pour une enquête
internationale transparente et claire
qui permettra d'assigner des
responsabilités des vrais pas celle que
vous et moi on peut déclarer
est ce que la france profite de la
continuité des mêmes dirigeants mais la
prends ça ne profite de rien ne vient
vous aider elle vient vous aider mais la
france elle n'a pas à se substituer à la
souveraineté libanaise et donc j'ai vu
là en même temps d'autres acteurs de la
société civile
mais quelque chose est en train de se
passer qu'il faut accompagner et ce que
je veux que vous touchez du doigt c'est
que c'était infiniment plus facile pour
moi de ne pas voir les forces politiques
j'aurais pu venir vous tenir ce discours
là
à vous j'aurais pu vous le tenir je leur
ai tenu à eux parce que c'est plus
difficile de le retenir face à face et
de leur dire je reviendrai le 1er
septembre
parce qu'il se trouve que vous les avez
élu dans un système type ne vous plaît
pas qui est un parfait vous les avez élu
pas moi vous peuple libanais vous voulez
l'échangé faut les changer dans un cadre
démocratique
vous pouvez exiger des choses j'ai
toussé pour cette exigence et je vous
dis en transparence que je leur ai dit
mais ne pas les voir les accusés
derrière sans leur parler c'est beaucoup
plus facile
vous me demander d'être comme un
contestataire je suis président de la
république française j'espère avoir fait
le plus utile pauvre monsieur le
président la toute dernière vous avez
parlé maintenant du mouvement et du coq
libanais vous parler de cela depuis le
17 octobre
est ce que c'est une invitation à une
autre révolution maintenant et est ce
que ça veut dire que pour vous la france
la légitimité des responsables
maintenant n'est plus comme comme
d'abord aux biens comme d'avant mais ce
qui est formidable dans vos questions
comme dans le dialogue que j'ai eu avec
la société civile même pas quel
responsable politique
et comme ce matin j'ai eu dans la rue
avec beaucoup de libanaises et les lib
et libanais qui m'ont dit revenez au
mandat quelque part vous êtes en train
de me demander d'être le garant d'une
émergence démocratique ou
révolutionnaire je parle la révolution
non pas le mandat non mais je suis
d'accord mais je me dois vous me dites à
moi si j'invitais une révolution ne
s'invite pas c'est le peuple qui la
décide c'est les forces politiques qu'il
est c'est là et donc non la contrepartie
de l'exercice auquel je viens de me
livrer quitte un jeu ininterrompue de
questions ça veut dire qu'il n'ya pas
d'interpellation c'était la dernière
question sinon après il faut qu'il y ait
un ordre pour qui la liberté ce que ce
que je veux vous dire par là c'est que
ne demandez pas à la france
justement de ne pas respecter cette
souveraineté je serai là à chaque fois à
chaque fois qu'il faut aider les
libanais les libanais croyez moi je
n'aurai aucune complaisance mais je
n'aurais n'ont plus aucune ingérence
je serai dans l'amitié et l'exigence
parce que je pense que c'est ça notre
histoire commune c'est cette histoire
qui s'est scellé il ya son temps et donc
il faut que les solutions émergent ici
qu'elle émerge du peuple des forces
politiques des forces économiques
sociales
vous avez cette force d'amener cette
intelligence pour que cela arrive je
ferai tout pour l'aider mais ce n'est
pas à moi à pointer du doigt en disant
c'est cela et ça doit se passer ainsi
c'est pas mon rôle c'est le vôtre non je
les dis sur la neutralité il a des
associations c'est ce à quoi je crois
vous remercie mais c'est elle qu'on a
lancé l'initiative
soyons clairs l'initiative c'est ce
qu'ont annoncé aujourd'hui c'est ce que
c'est ce que je porte depuis tout à
l'heure le président de l'ad-pa repartir
nouveau manager j'ai pris toutes les
questions aussi avoué initiative
politique c'est celle qu'on a lancé
aujourd'hui en demandant à toutes les
forces politiques au président de la
république au premier ministre au
président de l'assemblée de prendre
leurs responsabilités dans les semaines
qui viennent de lancer les réformes que
j'ai évoquées de lancer le processus
d'audit sans lequel l'économie du pays
s'effondrera et d'accéder un programme
fmi
c'est ça cette initiative et cette
initiative politique c'est celle qui
peut permettre avec un gouvernement
d'union nationale dans les prochains
mois ensuite de relever le pays est de
permettre aux forces économiques
sociales politiques d'émerger et de
décider avec les libanaises et les
libanais ce qui est bon pour merci à
vous